I am absolutely delighted it is about
Bloody time that the people who won the
Nobel Prize that um won it when I was a
student
you were told don't don't go there do
not go into the foundational aspects of
quantum you know what does it mean what
does an observation mean and just
calculate because it works so well this
is talking about weird Quantum States
right I mean this weird Quantum State
when it comes to Nobel prizes on the one
hand they kind of irritate me a bit
because they oversimplify you know there
were masses of people involved in this
work there was lots of background to it
there were lots of other people whose
contributions need to be recognized but
on the other hand it's just really good
to be able to celebrate excellent
scientists and clearly the three who won
are all outstanding experimental
scientists and it's great that they were
able to be awarded the prize in this way
my feelings about this Nobel Prize is
there's a real victory for the idea that
the universe is is a nature is
probabilistic that is that we live in in
the you know the underlying ingredients
of of space and time and the fabric of
voluminous is fundamentally
probabilistic that's what it comes down
to and that's what quantum mechanics
tells us and then we don't need to have
all this other you know extra
ingredients to just trying to strong
armor our sort of prejudice that somehow
everything needs to be deterministic but
now it's actually probabilistic this
year's Nobel Prize winners showed that
quantum mechanics is Right contrary to
Einstein and his colleagues who
published a very famous paper back in
the 30s called the epr paper Einstein
poldoski and Rosen
that claimed that well there's something
missing from quantum mechanics it
doesn't quite grasp the nature of
reality what this year's Nobel Prize
winners have shown is that well no I
know you're going to hate this and I
know it's really uncomfortable and I
know it's really unsettling but quantum
mechanics does get the nature of reality
what I'm most happy about is the fact
that they Vindicated uh is a really
famous
physicist a guy called John Stewart Bell
born in Belfast Northern Irish physicist
and he was the first to say well if you
do this type of experiment you make this
type of measurements and you look for
these correlations and you think about
the statistics then there is a way of
distinguishing between the quantum
mechanical View and the view put forward
by Einstein and on although she was
skeptical about a skeptical about
quantum mechanics and it was Bell's um
what's called Bell's inequality was
described has been described as the most
profound Discovery in all of science
it's that important because it's telling
us about the nature of reality very
coincidentally we talk about spooky
action at a distance but on the day that
the Nobel Prize was awarded 60 symbols
uploaded a video by Mike on the epr
Paradox as it's called Bell's inequality
and just what it's all about I'd love to
be able to claim it's because I had you
know a spy in the Nobel organization who
tipped us off but actually we didn't
it's a complete coincidence
um and actually I suspect the reason
it's taking taking us this long to get
round to doing a video on Bell's theorem
is it's really hard to understand I mean
it's one of those things I read the
paper and I kind of scratch my head and
I really focus on it hard it's a hard
bit of physics because it's actually
quite a complicated story that goes into
the theory but finally I kind of got my
head around it enough to make this video
about it a few weeks ago and so it was
the video was scheduled for release on
the day of the Nobel Prize by a complete
coincidence and so we were able to look
fairly psychic in coming up with this
video that came out you know within an
hour of the Nobel Prize being announced
we had a video out on the physics behind
the Nobel Prize this whole thing is all
about these um you know uh spooky action
at a distance as Einstein described it
of things being able apparently being in
contact within it with it with each
other when they're too far apart for
information to pass one to the other we
kind of did the same thing we were able
to produce a video faster than the
information could be brought together to
produce such a video but it's only
because we'd actually coincidentally
done it a week or so beforehand it's
gone to uh John Claudia
an aspect and Anton zellinger these guys
took seriously some original ideas of
Einstein Rosen and podolsky who were
worried about interpreting quantum
mechanics interpreting some of the
results of quantum mechanics that then
fed into
people like David bowm who sort of took
their concerns seriously and tried to
come up with a kind of alternative way
of understanding quantum mechanics which
would reconcile some of the issues that
Einstein was facing that then fed on to
John Bell who in turn realized he could
discriminate between the ideas of boom
and then the original ideas of quantum
mechanics and came up with this
beautiful mathematical formula which
ended up with this bound which if it was
violated meant that bombs what were
called hidden variable theories local
hidden variable theories couldn't be
right and and whereas you'd expect
quantum mechanics to violate it the
frustrating ass aspect of this is that
they don't award the Nobel Prize
posthumously so in the year that Bell
died which was 1990 apparently he was
going to be awarded the Nobel Prize it's
really a massive Injustice given that
you know his Discovery or his inequality
was described as the most profound
Discovery in science it's a real
Injustice that he didn't get the Nobel
Prize even posthumously I think we
should have a petition let's have a
petition that he's awarded posthumously
the point of it was was that he showed
there was an experiment that would
differentiate between whether quantum
mechanics was kind of the end of the
story and the universe was fundamentally
probabilistic or whether there was a bit
more physics that we just didn't know
yet which is a very clever thing to do
to be able to show that you can't there
can't be any more physics is really a an
impressive thing to do anyway it was a
way of distinguishing between these two
things and so this idea that you could
distinguish between these two things
even in theory was kind of impressive
but it sort of set the scene for an
actual experiment that could be done to
tell whether or not quantum mechanics or
was the full story or whatever there was
a bit more physics to discover it took a
long time it was one of those very slow
burn things partly because it was a hard
experiment to do
and partly because it was so it wasn't
terribly respectable to think about the
fundamentals of quantum mechanics it was
somehow it was just you know you should
be getting on and doing something rather
than actually messing around thinking
about sort of it was almost a
philosophical argument rather than a
physics argument of course the irony is
that at the end of it you know our
understanding of all the processes
involved in quantum entanglement and all
the stuff that goes into it is the basis
of a whole load of new physics a whole
load of new technology about Quantum
Computing and cryptography and all sorts
of stuff but anyway there was a
relatively smallish number of people who
were working on these experiments who
over time did a series of experiments to
try and show whether the theory that
Bella put together held up or not and
each time you do an experiment you know
you do the experiment you say well that
almost shows it but there's this little
loophole here and so there was this
series of experiments which successively
closed these loopholes off until
eventually they really have pretty much
been able to show that this bill's
inequality this bill's theorem shows
that quantum mechanics is the end of the
story what these three people have done
in this sort of over a series of of
experiments since the 1960s have
basically shown that this bound is
violated and therefore quantum mechanics
is looking as if it's in a really
healthy position and the Alternatives
like hidden variable theories at least
local hidden variable theories are in a
struggling to explain these and in fact
probably can be ruled out you have an
experiment in a Quantum level that that
really things come down to probabilities
now you know I can think about you know
tossing a coin and it has a probability
that goes heads or it goes Tails but and
you somehow that's kind of a bit
misleading because it seems like well it
depends on how I flick it you know and
so on and so forth so ultimately you
might think it's actually deterministic
but on a Quantum level you know that
there are genuine experiments you can do
where you really see that this and and
this is what's related to this Nobel
Prize that really the nature is
probabilistic that you can have a a say
an electron and you know when you you
might want to measure its Spin and
whether you measure the spin as being
sort of spin up or spin down
you know it's a truly probabilistic
thing it could be either and it's in
some sense both and until you perform
the measurements it's you don't know and
this is just how nature works on a sort
of the most fundamental level it really
is truly probabilistic some people
really struggle with that but I don't
really see why
I mean I always think of like a horse
race and there are probabilities
beforehand for one horse winning over
and not there and that's fine and then
the horse a particular horse wins the
race and nobody freaks out right that's
okay it's just probabilistic right but
what some people want a sort of strong
arm and what some people have tried to
do in the past is because they don't
like quantum mechanics and they don't
like the probabilistic structure of
quantum mechanics is they try to strong
arm some sort of determinism into it so
in the case of the horse race it would
be like saying well
I don't like the fact that there's odds
on the horse race I'm just gonna assume
that every race is kind of already fixed
now there might just be some I don't
know how it's been fixed maybe that
horse has been drugged or that horse has
been drugged so everybody's agreed that
this particular horse is going to win
and I just don't know about it and I'm
just that's why I work with with odds
but actually somewhere hidden in the
background there is some what we call
Hidden variables that magically or not
magically but it sort of conspired to
actually fix the outcome of the race
Nature's not behaving like that there is
no sort of conspiracy there is nobody
fixing the horse race of quantum
mechanics it just is what it is just
probabilities that and this is what this
Nobel Prize is really all about what
these guys showed ultimately through
their experiments was that the nature
really is probabilistic and that's that
um you know there are no sort of hidden
variables no hidden conspiracy or at
least locally which is which is sort of
fixing the outcome of the experiments
and it's just you're just not aware of
it there's no there's no none of this
hidden conspiracy it's there it's
probabilistic it's quantum mechanics and
it's the way nature is
just live with it
and um so my teacher was telling us this
and I began thinking oh my God yeah what
what's what's going on here you know
what how's the signal come from there to
there to explain it and um and he said
the teacher went on to say well this guy
David Bowie